welcome back to the YouTube live stage
here at PAX Prime 2015 I'm Chris waters
here from GameSpot the hosts some beat
downs with Peter Combofiend neuroses and
street fighter 5 Combofiend thank you
for joining me here on stage hey thanks
for having me dude it's exciting street
fighter 5 we got the the beta coming out
now on PlayStation 4 yeah the beta is
actually out today that now yeah all
right it goes up tomorrow I apologize I
got I got you know we're that no i'm
here at pax you know I'm here and I'm
thinking fina starts to eminently people
are gonna get a shot at street fighter 5
in the beta and people here in the
audience are gonna get a shot at taking
you on so let's call of our first
contestant here to come join us here on
stage come on over take seat on the
couch strike a pose uh there we go the
shrug of confidence yeah we're gonna get
the game going here and you guys are
gonna face off and we're gonna talk
about what we see in action all right a
little bit design in a second what's
couch a little bit school bit he's not
miked up so you stay on that couch stuff
that we don't want you guys mixing up
too much I don't try to look at my
controls man trying to get a read on the
situation I understand all right we're
gonna be getting the match going here
soon but tell us a little bit about the
build of street fighter 5 we have here
and where it's at right now so this is
the latest build it has Macaulay Vega
and our Miko who was just recently
announced yesterday mhm yeah the build
definitely has some battle balance
adjustments it's a little bit different
than the e3 build which I think was the
one that a lot of people have seen along
with the beta the I mean the beta
version is a little bit different than
this version okay oh yeah all right well
let's get up on here on these screens in
just a sec and we will get going but
tell us a little bit about our Mika cuz
she was just announced ya got the sizzle
trailer going she's like she's a pro
wrestler basically yes she is a pro
wrestler a lot of her moves have been
redesigned previously she had some grabs
in alpha 3 but they weren't all that
strong she'd been redesigned to have
things that look a lot more closer to
professional wrestling alright like like
professional wrestling though it but
more
more exaggerated like Street Fighter
ified of course you know i mean it has
to have that slightly exaggerated Street
Fighter feel to it but the moves are
inspired by real wrestling room all
right well maybe we'll see here in
action we've got the game up now so once
you guys grab your controllers yeah and
we'll get into a match here I wait we're
having a little input back and forth
situation so what Combofiend while we
wait for this to fire up oh you guys are
gonna be looking up on screen now all
right this is gonna be a might be a
little bit of a challenge okay we got it
here re gonna go for our Mika straight
on the gate or let me go Gengar begun
ready my visions all right hey I am very
excited about her she is an awesome
character okay so like yeah tell us a
little bit about her style I mean we
obviously are gonna see some wrestling
moves but in terms of what kind of
positioning what kind of pace she wants
to say it's uh she's a very methodical
methodical character you really have to
have a good understanding of what your
opponent will do a holly are properly to
the grappler a true graph
she doesn't have any projectiles she
doesn't really have any way in her
purple smart very long so it's not
really on you as a player to be able to
get in and uh you know be able to fight
we close the distance and get your mitts
on them exactly deliver some kicks with
those big boots alright so as you're
fighting here for folks who've been
following to read Fighter 5 see the the
beat trigger these skills weren't a
meter filling up at the bottom you'll
have to let us know whenever use that
sure but it's not looking good for rear
east go right here so what she does is
she starts talking into the mic oh
really and you know she's tight yourself
up once like I wrestlers when they cut
their promos uh-huh you know that sir
Mike performance and as the longer she
holds a mic push this place going and
when she finishes if she got to throw in
her throat was extremely powered up okay
there was like a little ground pound
almost that's the indicator that she's
getting more and more exclusive because
she's getting 10 fired exactly a fired
fired up to fight in what appears to be
like a traffic jam caused by Street
Fighter which is you know it happens
these are this is lou this is city
living
oh goodness
now did she have you know that sort of
picking her up and finding her at
spinning him around throwing him I
invokes that other grappler of Street
Fighter babe let your partner yeah yeah
let's talk about what's happening haha
because the tag team but head smash yes
he did a muscle bomber so when their
partner there who decides to come in and
help me so hurt v-trigger is that she
could call her partner in and her
partner could come from various sides GG
the games then thanks for falco all
contestants will be receiving a code for
the ps4 beta exactly and anyone who
takes you down we'll get a limited
edition Ryu faceplate there's only 200
of those maids so extra incentive for
our next contestant come on up buddy
yeah let's go have a seat and we'll get
the next match going ah alright i'm
still my mind is still grappling with
the fact that like a thought street
fighter was a one on one game what is
with the tag team partner racks ah you
know it's just her partner wants to get
it on the action too but we can only
have one wrestler character so you made
it mika instead of the desk oh yeah you
can't say you can't separate a tag team
I mean yeah so she had to get her time
to shine as well right so then alright
Vega and other characters talked about a
bunch last just last month maybe or yeah
yeah we were billed him daring gamescom
so kalan this version or Vega is
different because he can now choose to
take the claw he could fight with the
claw on or fall off and he has access to
a different special move with his claw
on versus off and your strategy also
kind of changes alright so with flow on
I'd imagine the strategy is a little bit
more the beeping distance exactly
but it is caught on and off something
that you can toggle on and offers it
like once you take it off the claw it's
off for the rest of the map oh no it's
on I mean uh it's on Finnegan and it's
off and let's back out okay he doesn't
just like tossing aside like oh goodness
welcome all birds is chained I mean it's
only fair good Samba feed now have to
focus as his health is a little less
than half birdy now taking a beating
that Las Vegas suplex honestly I don't
understand the back mountain to that guy
must have to be able to do such a move
on a girthy nude like birdie but there
it is yeah so uh yeah cloth the Vega has
very very very good range attack for it
he can fight like from here like take it
felt like I can hit him almost full
screen away you know it's like really
hard to fight have to kind of approach
him seeing a little chain ranch game as
well yeah but birdie no slash himself on
me and we'll fight opponent so far away
he has to chain impact he has a head but
stop moving forward like that haha you
can definitely get in our contestant
being a very great assistant for the
demo here i Solly he's hearing my cues
and it gets a bonus points for that like
that what you want
and still then compared to claw on fall
off or what we call this gallant Jack
claw claw the quarter banana and we're
dear littering not cool alright so
they'll help us Claudia is commando then
he can't normally do it it makes it
helps him be a little bit more offensive
because when the claws off you can no
longer run away because he's got his
yield yeah like you have to stay him
closer a little bit more or is he well
not with moves like that you know call
the way across the street foods on that
thanks for playing thanks for playing
another win for Combofiend and Vega
showing off some moves nice looking good
buddy your fingernails could use a trim
but that's fine alright got our next
contestant up here Hey lay some street
fighter 5 I we've seen our Mika seen
Vega who's up next I was trying to Kali
yeah you know the kali was also revealed
around evo and you know although people
have seen a few videos of him here and
there i don't think that anybody's
really shown but the character can do
all right you know a special moves and
things like that but the general move I
believe the technical term is hair freak
out there right oh when he activates his
feet trigger yeah hair freak out like
I'll saying yeah cuz man look at those
red lobster
that's why he like doesn't actually have
to work out he just gets those muscles
from maintaining that my hair weight on
his head exactly that's how you build
tell you for this run back alright so
what kind of fighter is Macaulay
basically primal like his style not
really a style just aggressive attacks
in clothes just want to get in and sort
of the opponent he has a book that uh
propel them forward always wants to be
near the opponent everything is just
about hurting the opponent like stops
look at that they're pretty vigorous I
all smashed the head of the pavement
tickets oh there we got hair freaked out
in action and wow I put the animation of
it like all of a sudden is blowing and
defying gravity and like eggs it's like
a head's on fire based like he's so
powered up he goes across to you know it
quoted his hair has muscles
you know everything about is just
scratching and clawing and really trying
to hurt your pony
walls vs clause here engine tech Kali vs
Vega
yes so that one thing you know once the
hair free couches the V trigger you know
I miss that happens this witness does it
change this sort of move set or style at
all doing attack take on the other
properties yeah some of it is packed aw
they hit a few more time so he does more
damage in general he does more damage
and he hits a little further so he
becomes a better character because he's
handling the inner power so is the goal
of every nickel ii player then going to
be just like get your hair freaked out
as fast as possible it takes a while but
I mean it's definitely worth doing but
at the same time when you activate this
the sacrifices be reversal so one of the
key tactics of the game becomes lost
because you can no longer put your
district your degage anytime okay sorry
your it's a it's a rhythm it does limit
you a little bit late
not too much barely good game thanks for
coming up and playing and we'll get the
next contestant up here maybe we'll see
another in a collie match just to give
people some moronic Ollie in action
unless there's another character you
wanted to move on I'll play whoever
you'd like me to play I want to see more
hair freak outs man I got it are you
have so like saying here freak out if
you guys haven't noticed her freak out
okay haha alright so once you grab the
controller and pick your pick your
player I so in terms of the beta now
that's going to be out on ps4 shortly is
this the character set that people are
going to be able to play with it is the
stage people are going to see oh no so
the beta is an earlier version it has it
has the six characters that were
previously announced Oh birdie kami
where you can sorry mac n Ryu kami
chun-li and bison and ash okay but has
six characters on it but Aspern akali
our nikah and Vega they're only here we
have let me unpack to be able to you oh
but people who are FX will be able to
play this build exactly where in these
halls yes I'm are from here very cool
alright we're seeing some Nash in action
Nash apparently pretty annoyed in the
Kali for like impinging on his hair game
exactly pretty proud of his hair
obviously but Macaulay just really
outdoing him in that snyol way
so for players of Nash we're looking to
play it him in the beta what would you
recommend in terms of like tactics to
try out we're not yet i would say they
have to really learn how much d trigger
works I think that his be trigger is
probably one of the more personal the
game all right tell me about it know
what when he activates to be trigger
it's a sudden move where he can either
appear right behind the opponent in
front of the opponent in the air or back
of the opponent in there so when used
properly it can create combos that are
otherwise impossible to do because she's
on both sides of the screen yeah and the
forget the intronic doesn't have you
know it's a must be so hard to
anticipate like what she blinks out
there on the other side somewhere it's
not that he always appears in the same
place right uh-huh everything's a PEZ um
he also has quite a few parking humble
and those are very necessary for you to
take me with him so clear goal and look
up what they are because they're up
there on the internet oh yeah I'll be
able to maximize
then I'm gonna make clear that I think
that's the lowest your health has ever
been so far are we gonna see a loss for
Combofiend here to nash oh we got a
Ralphie our seeds do Nash I suggest you
stay all right nice working little round
of applause for the competitor here we
got ourselves a match round two now
Peters just gonna solely focus it
I think it's fair to describe that is so
aggressive I mean every character
everything about it it's just a meme
book
got ourselves a good man here let me
call you using those sort of Browntown
ataxic damage at range and now he's in
full on here freakout mode you don't
know what that means Oh down to the wire
here folks it could end at any second
and it's gonna be oh he's so close oh
man closest it could be without a win
congratulations what a tight match Wow
right down to it and you pulled it out
Combofiend all right we got another car
are you feeling that was like I told me
I told me that I lost that actually when
he threw me I thought he was oh that's
it that's one faceplate guard the woman
player you okay we'll have a request
from the opponent all I would like to
say read see some reaction all right
it's just like opponents
counter-programming I know you wanted to
maximize his chances he's like if
there's one character I know it's with
you I see him to play Ryu and I beat him
up for you against ryu brother on
brother it's probably I brother I'm
brother it's like clone on phone hello
long clone again yeah it's alright like
look into the mirror even more sinister
now r you of course like classic
character but are there any sort of
fluff dates you have made to his youth
center street fighter 5 any kind of
sweet the play style hear that baby you
know people who main oh the show toast
aisle are gonna take pics look down
for that there was at least one trick
accessible I don't know if the character
that everybody has played everybody
knows how to make sure even the cheap no
ryu exactly so you know you want to make
sure that uh there's a character
everybody's to know your way but you
didn't change up this style a little bit
he's really balanced we're asking for
too much more on the defensive side now
you can play him anyway you really want
to and you get probably people really
good results right now what if i want to
hear a character that's balanced you
know that definitely sounds like an
accessible way to go look like the guy
i'm going to start playing with I'm
unfamiliar with the game but you then
see it like does that balance limit his
liability and sort of like high level
play like we see a lot of Ryu players
come on oh I get for you for you
honestly one of those characters that
gets better and better the better you
get aha because his roof edge is so
strong he has a tool for everything and
it really depends on us player to be
able to use them correctly I mean
sometimes I've seen character sometimes
just don't have the tools to be
effective an ex-ranger you know they
don't have a damage output I think me
who has like everything everything you
need to be competitive three fighter why
why would you choose anyone else he's
the total package exactly
but his hair game is pretty weak i gotta
say got a little head coughing not even
threaten together good gay men are we
gonna play around too or is that the
whole thing did that just happen so fast
he jumped his old about all right all
right ah that was some great competition
that was war one close match between the
guy and Irish you know I think I might
just give these guys basically it's not
an aussie oh they throw in some face way
sorry i understood you're getting better
close to but you know that guy who
almost one I mean it was so close I was
close all right well let's talk about
the beta one more time before we wrap it
up here give folks details on where it's
running and how they can get into it
sorry telling the beta man how sorry I
was mistaken the beta is actually up
right now BAM so if you're at home
download it if you can you know if you
pre-ordered the game didn't you have a
code you know and we'll see you on very
cool street fighter 5 when you guys
coming out we're coming out spring of
next year spring of next year but more
characters to come and more stratified
obvious in the coming months no doubt
exactly it'll stay tuned for the next
character alright Combofiend thanks a
lot for coming on stage showing it off
and folks if you want to keep up to date
on the latest in street fighter 5 go to
gaming calm / you gaming YouTube / calm
I'm gonna get it here it comes gaming
die youtube.com slash gamespot give us
an ad and you'll get up to date on all
that Street Fighter knowledge and all
the sarcastic applause I'm getting from
the crowd here at PAX Prime will be back
soon more game talk stick with us
you